There are a few really common pitfalls
that developers should avoid.
First and foremost,
it's using your analytics improperly.
A good example of this is
relying on vanity metrics.
Vanity metrics are things
such as daily active users.
These might be extremely large,
attractive numbers, 100,000, a million
people but they don't actually tell you
how the app or the game is performing.
You might have a huge number of people
but nobody's actually monetizing,
or the percentage of the people
that are monetizing,
even though the average revenue
per user is really high,
the percentage of total people who
are making a purchase is absurdly low.
You're leaving money on the table.
Make sure that you're not
relying on those vanity metrics.
Make sure you're tracking
exactly the right things.
Only things that actually determine
whether or not you're making money or
retaining users.
It might be interesting to see how many
people are engaging with the multiplayer
feature within your game but if it's
not actually contributing to your
monetization, the percentage of
people that are making a purchase or
sticking around or
sharing the game with their friends,
then it makes the most sense to
leave that out of your analysis.
Finally, when looking at your analytics,
make sure you're not getting
consumed with the minutia.
In a lot of cases, there will
be a great degree of noise but
not a whole lot of signal, particularly
statistically significant signal.
Make sure that in the end,
if you see a small day to day, or
week to week fluctuations that
you're only acting on it if it's
actually something that is significant.
One mistake that we see a lot,
is that developers rely on one
particular ad network, or a monetization
method for all of their monetization.
You don't want to put all
of your eggs in one basket.
Even if you have a great relationship
with whoever the person is that sold you
that particular method,
make sure that there are fallbacks,
just in case there's a problem.
Finally, don't use emotion or
don't rely on an emotion in
order to make your decisions.
Do everything based on the numbers.
There's great data somewhere out there
that's going to determine exactly what's
right for you,
all you have to do is find it.